which one is you like some 1 2 3 you
then yes yes yes 1 2 3 so who are you
and what are you currently busy with
well my name is Erika and I'm actually
currently busy doing animation artwork
and I'm actually doing a flimsy
fantasies review series here's - girl
[Applause]
did you have any idea you were the
inspiration for hyper fangirl I had no
idea my friends joked about it with me
they were like oh look at that because
you're like nostalgia critic so much
you're just like weird I'm like haha
that's funny and then one time I got a
message from you and I'm like wait wait
okay I hope it's all the positive things
and you're like yes yes it's all the
positive thing smells like oh okay do
you think you have any elements jewelry
that you would think are kind of oh yeah
we both are very energetic and very
enthusiastic like um I personally like
whenever I see somebody that I like just
try to talk to them as much as I can if
I can and if I can't that's okay
it's just one of those things this is
like wow I wanna get to notice person if
I can if I'm able to realize yeah what
is about the nostalgia critic that you
like the most
he makes me laugh he really is he's
really funny he actually like has a
point to what he says and that's what I
appreciate the most
and the Cat in the Hat review and he
goes on his soapbox and like tells the
world like no this is what dr. Seuss
meant to do when he was writing these
children's literature it's just that he
has such a compassion for like movies
and stories and just and that's
inspiring to me and that's what I like
about him the most and what was the
first time you met me oh I remember it
was a at Matsuri con I believe and I was
so nervous feeding you
oh wait you did ask it under Tommy was
so live and yeah I messed up by line but
it was still it was still a lot of fun I
like dancing and I also like doing art
work obviously and what kind of fan art
do you draw just a fun stuff mostly none
of its supposed to be taken seriously
sometimes I do draw chippy things little
turns on maybe maybe but excel but be
real with me who-who doesn't ship them
any fanfiction those written by you oh
dear I figured you would bring up that
uncle oh and Donny de pocky fanfic I was
so surprised that you found it I thank
you to his friend uncle yo found that
one oh I'm so happy when he did is he
had no idea that you wrote it in the
episode itself Donny was like I always
wanted a slash Vic of me and I just kind
of look around to my friends so I'm like
so am I gonna write this and nobody
volunteered and so I was just like well
I do have an idea but I don't know if I
should do it and my friend wouldn't do
it how does it feel to know that you
inspired a character that there's so
many people now are making drawings of
and plushies of and turn into such a
popular care it's awesome I always made
characters myself I never imagined
somebody wouldn't get character based
off me myself it's kind of cool I kind
of really like it the original thought I
had was coming up with a hyper fangirl
was kind of more of what Rachel was in
the table in South Park episodes which
looked a bit more mean and were me and I
realized that wouldn't be the route to
go I thought fans might take it the
wrong way I think I was insulting
numbers so whenever I was thinking of
this character and trying to explain to
people I'd say you know just really
bubbly really entertained like the
positive side of a really hyper fangirl
and I would just always keep coming back
to you thing like you know like that one
chick I'm rare that one chick we saw at
that con you know just really kind of
make
like her that's why I'm gonna sort of
try and do so yeah so just honestly
thanks for being the inspiration because
the character has become such a big hit
and one of my favorites all right thank
you so much I feel so honored
you
[Music]